[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber ich habe schlecht gefühlt wenn wir
schneller oder besser gewinnen und dann
habe ich mich irgendwann dafür
wunderkinder waren sie gummi und hanni
die zwei schwestern aus zürich die
mühelos schuljahr übersprungen haben und
vor allem als geigerinnen die fachleute
schon früh zum staunen brachten
wie geht es ihnen heute und wie
empfinden sie dieses prädikat im
rückblick davon erzählt dieser film
[Musik]
zürich im sommer 2006 die zwölfjährige
boni und ihre achtjährige schwester
hanni auf dem weg in den übungsraum wie
jeden tag verbringen sie auch während
der sommerferien einige stunden mit
geige spielen
bomi die schon als kleinkind das schüler
lexikon auswendig konnte spielt meistens
ohne noten
anfangs sprich schon nach noten habe ich
versucht so schnell wie möglich lernen
und dass gott damit gesagt ziemlich
schnell also mit auch mal sagen
praktisch andere sache konzentrieren
muss ich nicht immer das nötige die
eltern harry und cup kern song stammen
ursprünglich aus südkorea und sind für
studium in die schweiz gekommen
seit ihre töchter musikmachen verbringen
auch sie viele stunden im übungsraum
dort wo so mancher große karriere
geändert wir müssen ehrlich gestehen es
geht nicht immer das ist sehr menschlich
dass wenn sie müde sind sie haben ja
schule den ganzen tag
dann haben sie vielleicht noch andere
sachen und dann müssten sie ja noch üben
und das geht nicht immer und dann wir
forcieren nicht in dem sind aber wir
machen ein gespräch mit den und machen
darauf aufmerksam wie wichtig ist zu
üben und dann kommen sie und üben
und dann folgt gewissermaßen der lohn
für die mühe der auftritt an einem
openair boni hat ein ungarisches stück
ausgewählt eine pragmatische
entscheidung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
13 jahre sind seither vergangen die
schweiz haben die züchter hinter sich
gelassen mittlerweile leben die beiden
in münchen
das geigenspiel bestimmt aber noch immer
weitgehend ihr leben
rooney hat das musikstudium bereits
abgeschlossen hanni braucht noch ein
jahr bis zum master als töchter
asiatischer eltern waren sie vielen
vorurteilen ausgesetzt
erstellt wurde das als älteres voll
pushen hätte ohne dass dir überhaupt
alter kann ich will das halt so das
klischee ist und das hat mich am meisten
stört will das einfach überhaupt nicht
der fall ist und das geht das einfach so
im kopf hat dass alle asiatische ältere
kinder zwingen zum bürger und das heißt
und dass alle ja sie hatte keine
kindheit kann was überhaupt nicht stimmt
das hat man show steht die musik schallt
dazu etwas passiert eben nur drehen
sondern das ja absolut unmusikalisch
spielt also technisch perfekt aber
absolut unmusikalisch und ich glaube es
hat durchaus solide wo dann muss mit der
mit dem vorurteil danach schon zur klose
tanz und dann hätten wir nie hätten so
schön kann es spielt die dann einfach
immer kaiser ja ich spiele ja einfach
nur technisch hanni und boni besuchen
ihre eltern regelmäßig in der schweiz
vor allem wegen musikalischer projekte
beide spielen in verschiedenen
orchestern
seit jahren verdienen sich die zwei
geigerinnen so ihren lebensunterhalt
finanzieren ihr studium
und entlasten damit das familienbudget
auf die hilfe ihrer eltern sind die zwei
jungen frauen schon lange nicht mehr
angewiesen
[Musik]
ich denke es braucht schon die
unterstützung von eltern
wir haben uns vorgenommen
boni und hanni so zu fördern wie sie
sind wir wollten nicht aus einem kreis
ein dreieck machen sondern wir wollten
dass der kreis größer wird und grüßen
und natürlich muss es noch mehr reifen
aber ich denke sie sind auf dem besten
weg die user ist psychologin
spezialisiert auf die abklärung und
coaching von hochbegabten menschen für
sie ist klar
hochbegabung gedeiht nur unter gewissen
bedingungen trinkt und erwachsene sind
häufig sehr sensibel serafins in syrien
und wenn wohlwollen die menschen
sie fördere die dometic sind dann sind
sie wirklich offen dafür sie ihre
potenzial aber der gott sinne gut wenn
sie aber merkt das nicht im ruhm ich
dass das die abgewertet werden dann hat
sie das potenzial dann über trier
zurücknehmen und gar nicht machen zeigen
was sie sind und das führt dann zu dem
was man das rheder fachsprache
minderleister die bezeichnet
[Musik]
aufnahmen von gomis vierten geburtstag
seid ihr anderthalb ist kann sie lesen
koreanisch und deutsch
[Musik]
mit zwölf ist sie längst im gymnasium
drei jahre jünger als ihre
mitschülerinnen romy bringt auch
erfahrene lehrerinnen ins staunen nicht
finde ich dass sie sich trotzdem alte
unterschied so gut integriert und so gut
mitmacht dass man die ganzen in ganz
vielen situationen gar nicht merkt dass
sie so viel jüngere hanni steht der
großen schwester in nichts nach auch sie
ist ihren schulkameraden um längen
voraus
[Musik]
im moment ist ein leben auf der
überholspur durch die schule rasten die
song schwestern in beeindruckendem tempo
trotzdem blieb genügend zeit für ihre
große leidenschaft die musik sind ihre
immer treu bliebe ist dass irgendwann
einmal in frage stand
ich hab's nicht einfach kein mittel
gegen das werde ich mir vielleicht jetzt
einige lied nicht glauben aber ich kann
es schwierig so oft verzweifelt einfach
und so frustriert sie und so streng zum
jetzt auch ich habe mich gefragt wieso
mache ich sowieso später ausgerechnet
gegen ich hätte so viel einfacher
das hat er immer kaiser wie so etwas
sowieso markus kraft und musik ich
glaube ich habe die herausforderung
abruft und das müssen bewiesen ich kann
das jetzt auch
ja und sie der letzte sieg über klerus
größer sagen doch dass ich jetzt ein
teil von mir und das kürzel mir und dass
ich alles richtig so wie es ruhig sind
sie stolze 40
ja klar ich bin da sehr stolz auf meine
töchter nicht da weil sie etwas so gut
können oder weil sie so hoch begabt sind
sondern weil sie so sind da und weil sie
auf ihrem weg lebensweg gut gehen und
auch wirklich an am prozessor für die
reife dran sind
ich bin sehr sehr stolz auf unsere
töchter
ja es ist schön dass ihr sagen dass ihr
stolz auf euch so viel mehr sind nicht
weg dem was mir machen will
ja genau wie das ist sehr schön zu
erfahren dass mir die isu geborgen sind
und ja ich kann viel geld einfach nur
stolz sind und das ist dass ich extrem
wichtig für die filiale und irgendwie
auch der glaube ich glaube dass ich habe
es richtig spaß machen hier vertreten
egal was wir machen egal ob sie
hochbegabt die menschen werden noch mehr
als andere an der leistung gemessen das
bad einen großen druckaufbau hinderlich
als sie sind die höheren ansprüche wo
will ich hin entwickelt wenn es immer so
in einer asymmetrischen bezirk sind mit
andern sind das heißt wenn sigrid mitte
zieht immer sie hans schneider sie
begriffe schneller
dann entwickelte so eine art
hochnäsigkeit einer sieg gegen anders
könnte es macht total oder
perfektionismus wurde zur führt dass sie
selber wenn sie es nicht
super gut für dein leben und sich
zurücknehmen
[Musik]
hanni und boni traten seit jeher immer
wieder gemeinsam auf
ihr asiatisches aussehen und die
virtuosität schon im jungen alter
machten sie fast schon zu prototypen von
sogenannten wunderkindern
[Applaus]
im rückblick eine zwiespältige erfahrung
also c schaftliche ist eine negative
ständig also oder wenn das positiv
gemeint sich dann sind wir halt so
erklärt wurde wie also tier im zoo so
was so eine sensation nicht immer alle
da knapp also ja ich glaube jeder mensch
wird doch einfach in erster linie als
der mensch arno wunderlich und nicht
irgendwie aus der sensation oder als
irgendeine bis negativ also in der
schweiz sieht das immer direkt obwohl
ich wirklich wird viel gemacht und das
hat nicht ich habe mich immer dafür
geschaffen und jetzt heutzutage immer
wieder weg unbewusst anderer kollege vor
zu wenig für bismarck oder dass ich
irgendwie schlachter stellen also
schlachte darstellt als ich eigentlich
[Musik]
seit sie dreieinhalb ist spielt alison
guy ge
[Musik]
sie weiß ganz genau wie die stücke ging
war für harmonie das sind ganz
theoretisch hintergrund sie komponiert
dass nicht alle kinder macht es gibt
anders sehr begabten adolf das passiert
nicht so ticks motorkonzepte ganzes auto
geschrieben und diesen gut und das ist
doch nicht das ganzheitliche wobei er
mich besonders beeindruckten sie hätten
im innigkeit vor allem wenn sie langsam
stück gespielt wie dem motto green gibt
rudi rudi rudi stück wackeln und zwar
mit schwung und sie hat es mit möglichen
außergewöhnliche lief ich habe langsam
mozart konzert satz hat sie unglaublich
select und die musikalische live
[Musik]
inzwischen unterrichtet hanni selber die
arbeit mit den kindern macht ihr großen
spaß sagt sie
[Musik]
ich merke dass dies oft ein bisschen auf
der tiefen seite liegt wir machen wir
noch einmal die freude an der musik
weiter vermitteln ist beiden schwestern
eine herzensangelegenheit hier am
gymnasium moosach münchen machen sie das
heute im auftrag von rhapsody in school
eine initiative die sich genau dem
verschrieben hat schülerinnen und
schüler für musik zu begeistern
hanni und boni als botschafterinnen des
spiels ich bin die honey das ist meine
schwester pony ich bin 21 jahre alt und
sie ist älter sie ist 25 so und auch für
den rücken es ist eine nicht zu
unterschätzende belastung im orchester
sitzt man halt wir haben uns jetzt halt
sechs stunden so da mit der geige so und
versuche mal sechs stunden in der
haltung zu sitzen das ist schon muss man
aufpassen dass man sich nichts wehtut in
30 40 jahren und der wichtigste teil ist
üben üben üben üben
wer also im musikstudium was tut man so
drei vier fünf stunden am tag wenn es
mal brennt dann auch mehr
dann sperrt man sich auch mal ein und
übt dann halt auch mal acht stunden
wir haben euch jetzt so eine mischung
mitgebracht von allen möglich und was
man mit der geige zu tun kann
ich hoffe es gefällt euch viel vergnügen
[Musik]
die geige die mittlerweile leidenschaft
und beruf gleichzeitig ist sowie andere
liebt jeden tag ins büro geschafft mir
halt jeden tag ist halt irgendwie sind
aber sehr froh dass mir doch mit sehr
vielen nieder schafft könnte wie sie
natürlich es ist ein schönes gefühl wenn
das geld auch und was man macht wenn man
auf der bühne statt und erfreut hat und
dass ich immerhin aber man muss jetzt
nicht also ich mache es nicht nur für
das dass man auf einer großen bühne
statt vor zu sehr gut sondern ist auch
schön wenn du mir zuerst wenn ich spiele
das geht mir langsam
große auftritte hat es schon einige
gegeben zb 2012 als boni in der kirche
von wattwil
als solistin auftritt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch für die stets so abgeklärt wirkende
16-jährige ein emotionaler moment
[Musik]
große emotionen am anfang einer großen
karriere
aber die realität bedeutet harte arbeit
auch für eine überfliegerin wie boni bis
zur ersten festen anstellung sollen noch
ein paar jahre vergehen
in münchen ist es dann soweit und wieder
ein super gefühl für boni hier an der
oper wird die für ein jahr festes
mitglied des orchesters allerdings in
orchestergraben und nicht auf der bühne
bin auch gern mal im hintergrund
ich begleite aus äckern und es ist so
toll dass es dann am schluss des großes
ganzes wird dann das publikum selber
hund und mit wasser gefüllter dem wort
gibt organe
ich freue mich wahnsinnig bin sehr
gespannt was mich erwartet ich kann es
noch gar nicht aber ich bis jetzt nur
für sich von so einige kollegen keine
glanz und ich glaube dort werde ich sehr
viel
ja ich freue mich auf die neue
herausforderung und nicht
[Musik]
denn in den